John
Greg
you belong in a museum
no ticket guys what's this is a title
for it yeah
Destiny I'm learning this right now on
camera I didn't know that ladies and
gentlemen we got ourselves a minute 43
second trailer let's watch it what I
asked right now is you guys leave a like
I found this jacket in the closet it's
the closest thing to semi-resembling
Indiana Jones I can let's do it
[Music]
I miss the desert
laughs
I miss the sea
whoa whoa it was like pirates pirates
five yeah
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us sawa's voice I
think it's solo yeah I hear you're
supposed to be in those days of yeah
come and gone Perhaps Perhaps not
let's go and believe in magic
a few times in my life
Phoebe
wow
wow that was amazing
what you believe
it's during Apollo 11. hard to believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look at him go yeah get back
let's go that looks awesome it's a great
reversal on the classic scene damn that
the Aging was shocking
you know what I could not get over how
great that looked it was like
mind-blowing and I was not prepared at
all but mads Mickelson's in this
flashback too is this gonna deal with oh
there's internet even notice him that
time is it gonna deal with time travel
in some way ah you know I wouldn't put
it past them I'm not 100 certain I mean
maybe it just dives into you know a part
of Indy's history or whatever but also I
mean being that it is the space race I
don't know it's because mads Mickelson
doesn't look I guess he's a little
de-aged here yeah okay I guess men's
Nicholson that was a little bit because
it's just way less yeah the 1960s gonna
be the backdrop Indy being a man out of
time here I mean it looks like it has
the spirit of Indiana Jones I like the
fact that this one will be dealing with
his age it works to its strength you
know even when we saw some like top gun
Maverick where Tom Cruise was like
phenomenal at his age but I like how
that even that movie dealt with the fact
that he is older now and they're really
leaning into that and then here Harris
Ford's gonna be like 80 by the time this
movie comes out the way he's moving here
you know I remember like watching the
force awakens and Blade Runner 2049 and
well I think he did a great job in both
those movies there was stuff off about
the way when he was moving from like
showing but in this trailer I don't know
maybe they just found the right Clips
I'm like no he looks like he's moving
like back in now I want to say his prime
but it looks like he's moving better
than he did in those movies too oh sure
it makes me wonder I mean if the
de-aging technology alone is so crazy I
wonder what they're maybe able to do
with stunt performers and maybe you know
attaching his head to them or maybe he
just really you know wanted to throw
down and get as limber as possible for
this but I'm glad that it looks like he
is still capable and he is still filling
the shoes in a way that's not gonna be
like a bummer to watch yeah you know
just like the whole aesthetic too
because you know you associate Indiana
Jones with a lot of what you get here
these like temples and these you know uh
statues and these ancient artifacts but
also Nazis that's right you gotta get
those Nazis in there especially nowadays
yeah some famous rapper out there is
having a great time with this trailer
today who's that I couldn't imagine who
the guy who deserves to burn that's who
I'll say I also appreciate seeing Indy
in the context of yeah like the Apollo
11 parade and things that are more uh
you know at least more in Civilization
that's like you know a little bit of a
different place than we're used to
seeing Indiana Jones but because it's
the period and because of what the movie
is dealing with it seems like a clever
place to also you know kind of expand
the palette now who is Phoebe Waller
bridge going to be the goddaughter of
I mean not the goddaughter because
that's his goddaughter so he's got to be
the daughter of someone it could be
I mean marrying cream
or is it uh or is it Marcus Brody yeah
that's a good that's a good one because
it looks like it's tying it all in and I
think the best Indiana Jones movies are
often the ones that have uh that have
something to do with the Nazis seem to
be the best ones yes there's something
weirdly about that and it looks like
they're going back to the time of
Raiders of the Lost Ark I just can't
dial the destiny and I just I don't know
I get Time It's gotta be that something
and they're dealing with unless it's
just the backdrop to it but they seem to
like play with the actual events at hand
I'm not saying he's gonna have like a
time machine or something like that I
have been here for it I'll watch Jules
Vern's Indiana Jones I don't know if
they're gonna do that thing where Phoebe
Waller bridge is gonna be handed off the
Reigns here or something like that
people love that but this is the first
movie that Spielberg is not directing
out of the Indiana Jones franchise and
this seems to have like the earmarks of
the great James Mangold action sequences
like James mangle I think I like every
every one of the movies I've ever seen
him do even ones that aren't that highly
rated like night and day I like
everything this guy does he seems like
the love for Indiana Jones Is On full
display here but he's also bringing his
own Panache to the screen bringing Boyd
Holbrook over from Logan into here looks
great mads Mickelson as a villain not
what not Typecast
I'm getting Vibes of the forgetting the
guy's name to do with the burnt hand the
first one oh yeah yeah
something simple isn't it like probably
I forgot his name but I'm getting semi
Vibes of him there too I'm not gonna
pull it you should look at him yeah look
it up but it makes me wonder if they
might do something like that like I I
really trust James mangle to deliver
something that is you know like an
authentic story that isn't you know too
much in this sort of like hey reference
isn't cash crap but at the same time I
do wonder if we may be going back into a
time period of Indiana Jones that we're
already familiar with and maybe digging
out some kind of detail or you know
something that was happening uh
concurrently that will then inform this
new adventure or something like that I
also I hear this is going to be the last
movie that John Williams is going to be
scoring apparently like ever I think
yeah like last movie wow yeah that'll be
exciting damn yeah taught hey I guess it
would yeah just I have a I have a decent
memory of Indiana Jones because I
studied for the schmodown for it
yeah that's good
so that's why I have like a good memory
of it even I haven't visited the films
in a while either way man I mean I
thought this was actually a really
excellent trailer yeah I thought it was
I thought it was really Grand and
exciting and it looks beautiful and
Harrison Ford seems really excited about
it and he looks like he really showed up
to play so you know it doesn't look like
you're just kept phoning it in from the
enthusiasm you talked about a d23 I feel
like it'll be an exciting time I do too
but guys what did you think about the
Indiana Jones trailer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like click that Bell Also let's
end this with a
David Gandy you just seem like the guy
to shout out when it comes to Indiana
Jones you just I think I think we've
talked about Indiana Jones before yeah
it's just when it comes to like
swashbuckling old-timey films you're
easily the one in our patreon page to
think of and dude um I know you're uh
you're a Christian man and I hope that
this Christmas season you have a
Splendid Christmas with uh the family
you're able to be with and I hope you
actually attend church that day yeah I
want that for you three hours I want you
to go to that three hour Candlelight
visual yeah no don't you don't it's
supposed to be like serious somber
Christmas it's not Catholic Oh
Chris Christians so he gets to have like
a Monica more joy than we they're gonna
have like a band oh they're gonna have
like a lively yeah
Christian Church is fun oh I'm not even
a Christian but I've been to Christian
churches in Christmas and they are fun
Indiana Jones it is like a Church
concert event
um not like what we grew up with I know
anyway David so I had a crush for us
[Music]